bonjour Rémi bonjour Isabelle alors sur
quelle base on s'appuie mais l'avocat de
du recours collectif s'appuie pour
demande et ça interdiction de
communiquer avec bien à la lecture de sa
demande qui est très intéressante
d'ailleurs
on c'est un jugement de la Cour
supérieure qui avait été rendu dans la
cause des frères maris là après la
demande d'autorisation collective a été
accordée où là on avait fait le
raisonnement que puisque un avocat ne
peut contacter selon son code de
déontologie de la partie adverse qu'il
s'est représenté par avocat sans
l'autorisation ou la présence de son
avocat évidemment et bien la même
protection devrait être offerte au
membre de recours collectif on ne
devrait pas permettre à l'avocat de la
partie défendresse de les rencontrer
sans avocat bon alors normalement c'est
d'avocat à avocat ou de victimes à de
partir
exactement là ici l'action collective
est pas vraiment autorisée on
pas encore débattu de cet autorisation
est-ce que ça change quelque chose dans
le statut des personnes
ça c'est la question très intéressante à
laquelle le juge devra répondre parce
qu'effectivement le groupe n'a pas
encore été cristallisé on a même pas
autorisé le recours collectif on peut
pas présumer qui sera autorisé si on
regarde ce que la Cour d'appel a dit
dans le dossier de Monsieur Rozon il est
permis d'en douter mais bon c'est un
autre débats c'est autre chose c'est pas
le même genre de plaignante non plus
mais c'est d'abord il y a comme quelque
chose un peu de théorique le recours on
sait pas s'ils vont être accueillis et
les membres sont pas encore cristallisés
non plus alors dans dans se mesure là si
par exemple le défendeur en théorie les
contacter ben il y aurait le droit
maintenant comme c'est un avocat qui les
contacts et qu'elle serait peut-être
éventuellement représenté là ça soulève
des enjeux déontologiques peut-être ça
sera et c'est pour ça que ça va être
très intéressant de voir quelle sera la
discussion parce que à mon sens quand
même on a raison de dire que le ces
gens-là sont pas encore membres de
cristalliser un vrai groupe mais d'un
autre côté si on interdit à l'avocat de
les rencontrer ben vu ce qu'on reproche
aux défendeurs on n'est pas pour
permettre aux défendeurs d'aller les
contacter directement
si une entente était conclue imaginons
est-ce que cette entente là pourrait
comporter une clause qui interdirait au
fait de parler à la police de porter
plainte à la police vous pourrez
demander à certaines qui ont porté
plainte de retirer leur plainte
ce genre de clause là il y a fort à
Paris qu'on les jugerait contraires à
l'ordre public on peut conclure des
transactions pour mettre fin à des
litiges on peut prévoir toutes sortes de
clauses dans celle-là incluant les
clauses de confidentialité des clauses
pénales lorsque ces clauses de
confidentialité là sont violées mais
c'est certain que de prévoir par exemple
je m'engage à pas aller porter plainte à
la police normalement ça passe pas et
les avocats sont plus habiles que ça
habituellement je vous connais oui vous
êtes nécessairement plus habile mais
parlant d'habilité la confidentialité je
sais pas vraiment à droite ce que ça
veut dire normalement c'est pas le droit
d'en parler à personne alors si tu dis
pas va pas à la police tu dis par contre
tu as pas le droit d'en parler à
personne alors si tu veux porter plainte
à la police est-ce que tu violes ton
entente de confidentialité et bien ça
c'est une excellente question et vous
voyez quand je disais qu'on était habile
quand on les rédige mais c'est ça c'est
qu'on va assez ce que ça veut dire c'est
qu'on va prévoir qu'on ne peut pas en
parler à qui que ce soit et là souvent
on va prévoir des pénalités si ces
cloches là sont violées et effectivement
le fait d'aller en parler à gauche à
droite ou même à un inspecteur de police
en droit civil ce serait probablement
une violation de l'Entente est-ce que
maintenant un juge par exemple d'une
cour criminelle serait les mains liée
par ça
qui serait allé porter plainte à la
police pour ce je sais pas moi usé de
son droit alors qu'on s'est engagé à ne
pas en parler la personne mais ne pas en
parler à personne c'est pas ne pas
dénoncer un comportement criminel parce
que là c'est j'achète ton silence en
gros c'est ça oui mais en droit civil
par contre ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
ces clauses là sont légales c'est le
fait de renoncer un droit civil par
exemple de dire moi j'aurai un droit
d'action contre Pierre Jean-Jacques pour
avoir subi toutes sortes de ces vis des
violences etc puis je choisis tu es en
échange une contrepartie évidemment de
garder le silence et bien ça non
seulement c'est légal mais c'est aussi
encouragé à chaque jour on entend les
gens nous dire en haut lieu il faut
régler les causes à l'amiable les
tribunaux sont engorgés alors et non
seulement il y a cet argument là mais il
y a aussi un argument
l'argument éthique peut être facilement
retourné de l'autre côté aussi une
victime là quand on sait que le
processus judiciaire a parfois peut être
extrêmement traumatisant que ça peut
être vécu vraiment de façon violente par
les gens lorsqu'on a la chance de faire
de régler quelque chose hors cours du
jour au lendemain sans avoir à témoigner
en empêchant souvent
l'équivalent de plusieurs années de
salaire c'est qui sommes-nous à ce
moment-là pour dire aux victimes qu'elle
devrait pas faire ça aussi qu'elle
devrait absolument passer par le
processus judiciaire criminel WhatsApp
bon alors tout ça est captivant on
pourra en parler assez longtemps et je
gage qu'on en reparlera merci beaucoup à
Rémi Bourget avec plaisir au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI